[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis ein schönen Samstagabend
wünsche ich Ihnen WM EM und Fußball
gleich von Norbert Lehmann
und das sind unsere großen
Nachrichtenthemen
ampelstreit über die
Kindergrundsicherung Kanzler Scholz
kündigt eine Einigung in wenigen Tagen
an
Vorwürfe gegen weihanger der
stellvertretende Ministerpräsident
Bayern soll nach einem Medienbericht als
Schüler ein antisemitisches Flugblatt
verfasst haben
kleinformatig und abstrakt die
künstlersammlungen Dresden zeigen über
malte Fotografien von ausnahmemaler
Gerhard
[Musik]
seit Monaten wird in der Koalition um
die Kindergrundsicherung gerungen vor
allem Finanzminister Lindner und
Familienministerin Pauls liegen sich
über die Kosten in den Haaren jetzt soll
es laut Kanzler Scholz in den kommenden
Tagen eine Einigung geben am Dienstag
und Mittwoch trifft sich die Koalition
zu ihrer Klausurtagung auf Schloss
Meseberg lass wohnsack berichtet
das staatliche Leistungen für Kinder
zusammengefasst werden sollen das ist
Konsens in der Regierung nicht aber die
Höhe und das wie der Landkreistag war
von neuer Bürokratie wenn nicht mehr wie
bisher die Jobcenter zuständig sein
sollen es ist zwar eine gute Überlegung
die Leistungen für Kinder in Deutschland
bündeln zu wollen aber dies bei der
Familienkasse Anhänge ich zu machen bei
denen mindestens 300 neue Behörden
geschaffen werden müssen in Deutschland
ist ein Unding wir werden die Bürokratie
so mit Hilfe von Frau Pause und der
Ampel ausweiten und nicht eindämmen
gestern haben die Familie Ministerin und
der Finanzminister wieder einmal
versucht sich zu einigen wieder einmal
vergeblich der Bundeskanzler und die SPD
wollen dem Streit nicht länger zuschauen
und setzen eine Frist ich wünsche mir
dass diese Sachen auch geräuschloser
verlaufen dass man miteinander
verhandelt ist völlig in Ordnung da
gibt's unterschiedliche Interessen aber
für mich ist auch klar nächste Woche
muss es sein Ergebnis geben und doch das
macht Wort du kannst das scheint bei der
FDP zu verheilen aus der Fraktion heißt
es mit einer Einigung bis zum Ende der
Klausur in Meseberg sei nicht zu rechnen
da appelliere ich auch an die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
SPD-Fraktion inklusive des Kanzlers da
nicht Zeitdruck zu machen um das
Zeitdrucks und eine Einigung Willen die
am Ende zu kurz greift weil wir
politisch und die Details so noch nicht
geklärt haben können zwei Tage dauert
die Regierungsklausur in Meseberg nach
der heutigen Aussage der FDP könnte die
Hängepartie der Ampel auch danach noch
weitergehen
schwere Vorwürfe gegen den bayerischen
Vize-Regierungschef Hubert Aiwanger von
den Freien Wählern er soll in seiner
Schulzeit ein antisemitisches Flugblatt
verfasst haben berichtet die Süddeutsche
Zeitung Aiwanger weiß das zurück er habe
das Papier nicht verfasst der Verfasser
des Papiers sei ihm bekannt er werde
sich selbst erklären ließ aiweiler in
Bayern sind Anfang Oktober
Landtagswahlen Brigitte sah
zum Einzug aufs Augsburger Volksfest den
Plärrer kommt Markus Söder heute ohne
seinen stellvertretenden
Ministerpräsidenten der hat kurzfristig
abgesagt laut einem Bericht der
Süddeutschen Zeitung steht Hubert
Aiwanger im Verdacht als 17-jährige
Schüler ein antisemitisches Flugblatt
verfasst zu haben das sind schlimme
Vorwürfe im Raum dieses Flugblatt ist
der
menschenverachtend und geradezu eklig
diese Vorwürfe müssen jetzt einfach
geklärt werden sie müssen ausgeräumt
werden und zwar vollständig für Söder
ist die Sache unangenehm will er doch
nach der Landtagswahl eigentlich die
Koalition mit Aiwanger und den Freien
Wählern fortsetzen von der bayerischen
Opposition kamen heute deutliche Worte
wer so denkt wer so schreibt wer so
redet zeigt seine antisemitische Haltung
und wenn sich diese Vorwürfe
bewahrheiten dann muss Markus Söder
Hubert Aiwanger entlassen Hubert
Aiwanger hat die Vorwürfe zurückgewiesen
er habe das Flugblatt damals nicht
verfasst ich erachte den Inhalt als
ekelhaft und menschenverachtend der
Verfasser des Papiers ist mir bekannt er
wird sich selbst erklären
der Fraktionsvorstand der Freien Wähler
Bayern hat sich heute hinter Aiwanger
gestellt der Vorsitzende erklärte er
habe von Aiwanger noch nie eine einzige
antisemitische Äußerung gehört
Stefan Leif hat in München was heißt das
jetzt für den Wahlkampf
das heißt vor allem dass dieser
Wahlkampf sechs Wochen vor dem Wahltag
jetzt ein ziemlich schmutziger geworden
ist es steht Aussage gegen Aussage und
es steht ziemlich viel auf dem Spiel auf
der einen Seite die Reputation
Reputation des bayerischen
vizeministerpräsidenten Hubert awanger
und auf der anderen Seite die Reputation
von Bayerns wohl wichtigste Zeitung
solange Hubert Aiwanger die Vorwürfe
gegen ihn nicht zweifelsfrei ausräumt
solange werden in die Fragen im
Wahlkampf begleiten und er kämpft jetzt
für seine Version dass er Opfer einer
Kampagne geworden ist ein Problem Hubert
aiwangers ist immer auch ein Problem
oder eine Belastung für Markus Söder
nicht nur weil der schon fünf Jahre an
der Seite von Aiwanger regiert sondern
sich sehr kategorisch festgelegt hat
dass auch in den nächsten fünf Jahren
wieder tun zu wollen diese Sicherheit
könnte mit den heutigen Tag nun Risse
bekommen haben wie auch immer die
Geschichte aus geht heute schon auf
jeden Fall dieser bisher recht statische
Wahlkampf hat mit der Geschichte von
heute eine neue Dynamik bekommen
danke für diese Einschätzung Stefan
Seifert
auch ein Hessen wird in sechs Wochen ein
neuer Landtag gewählt die Parteien
starten jetzt in den Wahlkampf
Ministerpräsident Boris rein von der CDU
stellt sich zum ersten Mal zur Wahl er
hatte vergangenes Jahr von Volker
Bouffier die Führung der schwarz-grünen
Koalition übernommen für die SPD geht
bundesinnenministerin Nancy sein ins
Rennen aus Wiesbaden
Ministerpräsident Boris rein hat Grund
zum strahlen wie hier bei einem Besuch
der Wasserschutzpolizei Umfragen sehen
seine CDU aktuell als stärkste Kraft in
Hessen wichtig ist aus meiner Sicht das
eine Koalition Unterführung der Union
zustande kommt weil wir natürlich uns
massiv abheben auch im Stil und im
Umgang von dem was wir derzeit an der
Ampel bei der Ampel in Berlin erleben
seit 10 Jahren regiert in Hessen
Schwarz-Grün der stellvertretende
Ministerpräsident und
Wirtschaftsminister Tarek Al-Wazir von
den Grünen würde gerne vorrücken und
Regierungschef werden
die Menschen wissen dass wir hier sehr
verlässlich arbeiten und trauen dann
auch gerade den hessischen Grünen
einiges zu und der Wahlkampf beginnt
jetzt erst
bundesinnenministerin Phaser tut mit dem
Kanzler als Spitzenkandidatin für die
SPD durchs Land und trotz des
ampelstreits in Berlin schließt sie eine
Hessen Ampel nicht aus
ich würde meiner Partei immer
Konstellationen empfehlen wo wir viele
sozialdemokratische Themen umsetzen
können in welcher Konstellation das auch
immer dann ist es gibt eine Ausnahme
niemals mit der AFD
die AFD wird aber wohl weiterhin im
hessischen Landtag vertreten sein
vermutlich deutlich zweistellig sie
profitiert vom Gezänk in Berlin viele
Menschen machen sich Sorgen um die
Zukunft Deutschlands wir sind die
einzige Partei die dieses Chaos nicht zu
verantworten hat die FDP wirbt mit einer
feurigen Wahlkampagne will auffallen und
setzt mit Stefan naß auf einen neuen
Spitzenkandidaten um über der 5% Hürde
zu bleiben
wir wollen die hessische Wirtschaft
voranbringen wir wollen die Bildung in
Hessen voranbringen wir wollen raus aus
der Mittelmäßigkeit dieses Land wird
schlecht regiert wir wollen Schwarz-Grün
beenden für die Linke ist es schwer seit
dem Abgang von Janine Wissler nach
Berlin und den Querelen auf Bundesebene
sie betont das Thema Sozialpolitik da
stellen wir fest dass nach zehn Jahren
schwarz-grüner Landesregierung die
Verkehrswende stockt die Zahl der
Sozialwohnungen abgenommen hat dass die
Armut dramatisch zugenommen hat der
Wahlkampf nimmt langsam an Fahrt auf
sechs Wochen vor der Hessenwahl
bei einem russischen Angriff auf die
ostukrainische Stadt kobiansk sind zwei
Menschen ums Leben gekommen eine Rakete
waren einem Café eingeschlagen an den
Frontlinien toben weiter erbitterte
Kämpfe im Süden versuchen die
ukrainischen Truppen weiter die
russischen Linien zu durchbrechen
es ist eine verlustreiche Offensive hier
Soldaten kämpfen an gegen tief
eingegrabene russische Stellungen teils
zu Fuß stürmen sie über die gewaltigen
Minenfelder im Süden von saporicia neben
ihnen schlagen Drohnen und Granaten ein
seit Anfang Juni kämpfen sie so und sind
bislang nur schleppend vorangekommen
doch nun ist ihnen angeblich einen
entscheidender Durchbruch gelungen
wir haben die Hauptstraßen die besonders
stark vermiet waren passiert nun kommen
die Linien wo wir besser vorrücken
können ich bin sicher dass wir ab jetzt
schneller vorankommen werden
wenn das so stimmt dann wäre robotine
vollständig befreit und damit eine
Hauptverteidigungslinie Russlands
überwunden die Ukraine könnte weiter
marschieren Richtung militopol und
bergjansk auch für die Regionen meldet
Kiew zurückeroberte Gebiete ebenso nahe
bachmut
um die seit Monaten umkämpfte
industriestatuben weiter heftige
Gefechte mit großen Verlusten an
Menschen leben doch nördlich und südlich
der Stadt haben Truppen der Ukraine
wichtige Anhöhen seit Anfang Juni
zurückeroberten
russlandsarmee hat weiter nördlichen
Gebiet harkev Entlastungsangriffe
gestartet bei einem Beschuss wurden nach
ukrainischen Angaben mindestens zwei
Zivilisten getötet für das Gebiet um die
Stadt kopiansk meldet Moskau seit
einiger Zeit militärische Erfolge
10.000er ukrainische Soldaten und
Soldatinnen sind laut Schätzungen im
Krieg bereits getötet worden und wo noch
mehr erlitten Verletzungen viele sind
von den Kämpfen traumatisiert in
Einrichtungen der Armee bekommen sie
Hilfe wie ein Haken dort sind seit Juni
vergangenen Jahres etwa 2000 Soldatinnen
und Soldaten behandelt worden eine brüll
war dort
Vita liefer brennt das Bild dass er
gemalt hat weil er einfach nur vergessen
will wie das war an der Front in bachmut
dieser 120 mm Mörser hat alle meine
Waffenbrüder getötet die starben alle
vor meinen Augen ich bin der einzige
Überlebende
das Trauma des Kriegs lastet schwer auf
ukrainischen Soldaten in einer
Einrichtungen sie Hilfe Sport Therapie
ausruhen auch wenn es nur für 14 Tage
ist
wir arbeiten mit psychologischen
Problemen die bei den Militärs entstehen
das sind erhöhter Ängstlichkeit das kann
Aggressivität sein
Kommunikations- und Verhaltensstörungen
Suizidgedanken
sozusagen
er will jede Sekunde hier einfach nur
genießen
wenn ich hier bin kriege ich gar nicht
mit dass es Krieg gibt es ist wie früher
noch vor dem Krieg still ruhig
hervorragend positive Emotionen
dürfen dabei sein viele hatten seit
Kriegsbeginn kaum Zeit füreinander
sich nach eineinhalb Jahren
wiederzusehen das bedeutet einem viel
eine Auszeit einen geschützten Raum für
alle auch darum geht es bei der Therapie
nicht nur Soldaten leiden unter Stress
alle anderen auch alle Ukrainer sind
durch den Krieg gestresst das sind diese
täglichen Bombardierungen täglichen
Raketenangriffe der Russen
sie alle hier wissen je länger dieser
Krieg dauert desto größer wird die
Aufgabe die noch auf sie zukommt
und wir blicken kurz nach Florida von
dort aus hat sich eine neue Crew auf den
Weg zur Internationalen Raumstation
gemacht in der Morgendämmerung
verfolgten Schaulustige den
reibungslosen Start der Rakete des
unternehmensspace-ex von Cape Canaveral
Kommandantin ist die US-Amerikanerin
mobbelly die in Deutschland geboren
wurde außerdem sind noch ein Döner ein
Japaner und ein Russe an Bord sie sollen
die ISS morgen erreichen und dort sechs
Monate forschen
seine Werke zählen zu den teuersten die
auf den Kunstmärkten der Welt gehandelt
werden Gerhard Richter Maler Bildhauer
Fotograf oft verbindet er den die
künstlerischen Ebenen so auch bei seinen
Werken die jetzt im Albertinum gezeigt
werden übermalte Fotografien neue
Realitäten hier ganz groß in deutlich
kleineren Format hat Sie Thomas Bersch
in Dresden entdeckt
der Besucher muss wohl etwas genauer
hinschauen möchte er sich die 72 über
Marken Fotografien Gerhard Richters im
Dresden Albertinum erschließen Werke bei
denen auch der Zufall regie führte
das könnte ich auch dachte diese
Besucherin erst zeigt sich nun aber
sicher dass es sich um Kunst handelt
definitiv
Gerhard Richter schuf seine abstrakten
Werke mit der sogenannten Rakel an der
am Ende des Tages Farbreste haften
blieben durch diese Farbreste nun zog
Richter ausgewählte kleinformatige Fotos
aus dem privaten und beruflichen Umfeld
das ist praktisch einerseits Prinzip
Zufall und andererseits aber natürlich
auch von ihm durchaus gesteuert man ist
es getupft mal ist es hart man erkennt
einen Bildern der durch Gestik gesteuert
hat und das kann man direkt
nachvollziehen manchmal ergänzt die
Farbe dabei das Motiv manchmal verdeckt
Sie es und manchmal erzeugt sie
Illusionen wie die Landzunge die ins
Meer ragt oder wie die von Blättern
eines Baumes im Bild Vordergrund im
Grunde ist das ein Lebensthema
fotografische Bilder Realismus und
abstrakte Malerei und hier kommt das auf
kleinsten Raum so wunderbar zusammen wie
an keiner anderen Stelle in seinem Werk
die übermalten Fotos tragen nur das
Entstehungsdatum keine Titel so bleibt
es den Besuchern überlassen was sie in
ihnen entdecken und was nicht bis
November haben sie dazu Gelegenheit
immer wieder kommt es auf den
Fußballplätzen der Republik zu
Gewaltausbrüchen unter Zuschauern unter
Spielern und oft sind die Schiedsrichter
Zielscheibe von Aggressionen
eskaliert ist die Lage zuletzt im
Münsterland im Fußball Kreis Beckum
deswegen fällt dort in der Kreisliga
jetzt ein ganzer Spieltag aus dominik
hat recherchiert
vor zweieinhalb Wochen in Beckum ein
Kreispokalspiel artet in eine
Massenprügelei aus die Saison ist da
erst wenige Tage alt vor einer Woche
muss im selben Kreis ein Schiedsrichter
in seine Kabine flüchten und auf die
Polizei warten weil er so massiv bedroht
wird Gewalt scheint mittlerweile im
Kreis Beckum zum Fußball dazu zu gehören
auch Schiedsrichter hamsakao musste vor
ein paar Jahren diese Erfahrung machen
da wurde ich wirklich kurz nach der
Halbzeitpause
da die Mannschaft schon zur Halbzeit
gefühlt alle verwandt war umgetreten
nach dem Spielabbruch ja gut ich war
Sekunden langweilig bewusstlos
anscheinend auf dem Boden wegen der
jüngsten Gewalt Eskalationen finden an
diesem Wochenende hier keine Kreisliga
Spiele statt der Spieltag fällt aus so
die Entscheidung vor ein paar Tagen
wir wollen dann Zeichen setzen und den
Idioten auf den Fußballplätzen zeigen
dass wir das nicht tolerieren denn die
Gewalt hat zugenommen in letzter Zeit
beobachten Verbände und Soziologen
zielgerichtete Strafen wie
verpflichtende schiedsrichterkurse für
gewalttätige Spieler könnten Abhilfe
schaffen wir haben da sehr gute
Erfahrungen mit gehabt weil die Spieler
dann gemerkt haben also selber gepfiffen
haben dass der Schiedsrichter nicht
gepfiffen hat weil er in transalieren
wollte sondern hat so gepfiffen war das
nicht anders sehen konnte und das wird
natürlich dazu dass ich auch mein
eigenes Verhalten besser in Griff
bekommen mehr Präventionsprogramme und
härtere Strafen haben die Fußball liegen
in Nordrhein-Westfalen beschlossen um
solche Szenen künftig zu unterbinden
so jetzt kommen
in Mönchengladbach damit die deutschen
Frauen Bronze geholt 13 und dem kleinen
Finale gegen England schon in der
Vorrunde hatten sie sich gegen die
Britinnen durchgesetzt auch heute wieder
klarer Sieg ein persönliches Ende für
die Deutschen noch die Frauen bei dieser
Heime
die Mannschaft von Valentin Altenburg
soll im Spiel um Platz drei wieder Tore
schießen Kapitän und Sonja Zimmermann
macht den Anfang 1:0 in der zwölf
Minuten nach einer knappen halben Stunde
Führung aus
die Engländerin spielen die Schlussphase
ohne Torhüterin das heißt das Tor ist
leer Jette fleeschütz nutzt das kurz vor
Schluss 3:0 steht es am Ende immerhin
Platz drei bei der heim
Europameister wurden übrigens die
Niederlande die Titelverteidigerin
gewann heute das Finale gegen Belgien
mit drei zu eins die deutschen Männer
haben ihr Halbfinale gegen England
gestern am knapp verloren
0:0 stand es zum Ende der regulären
Spielzeit entscheiden durch Penalty
schießen Englands Kapitän AMS zum fünf
zu vier ja und dann scheitert Matz
grambusch am britischen Torwart
mazzarello Deutschland spielt morgen
gegen Belgien und Bronze
und das können sie morgen bei uns im
Livestream sehen ab 12:30 Uhr bei
sportstudio.de zur Leichtathletik WM in
Budapester hat der deutsche Zehnkampf
Shooting Star Leo Neugebauer weiter
Medaillon Chancen nach acht von zehn
Disziplinen liegt der auf Platz 2
Neugebauer jedoch nicht mehr mit der
Leichtigkeit des ersten Tages und nun
Außenseiter im Kampf um die Medaillen
wegen seiner Schwäche in den
abschließenden Disziplinen dem
Speerwerfen und dem 1500 Meter Lauf
ordentlich dagegen seine Leistung im
Stabhochsprung fünf Meter 10 so liegt er
nach 8 Disziplinen als zweiter nur noch
knapp vor Olympiasieger Damien Warner
aus Kanada Leon Neugebauer führte zur
Halbzeit gestern Abend der Hürdenlauf
heute und auch das Diskuswerfen aber
gelingen im gar nicht mit dem Diskus
bleibt der mehr als 7 Meter unter seiner
Bestweite 47 Meter 63
auf Goldkurs der Kanadiers de page nach
seinen fünf Metern 20 im stadtbuchsprung
zur Fußball Bundesliga der hat Union die
Tabellenspitze übernommen durch den Sieg
in Darmstadt jede bisherigen Ergebnisse
des zweiten Spieltags Darmstadt
unterliegt Berlin 124 Bochum Dortmund
1:1 Freiburg Bremen 1:0 Köln Wolfsburg 1
zu 2 Heidenheim gegen Hoffenheim 2:3 das
Abendspiel Gladbach gegen Leverkusen
ausführlich bei uns im Aktuellen
Sportstudio 23 Uhr bereits gestern
Leipzig gegen Stuttgart 5:1 ja kurzer
Blick auf die Tabelle ganz oben Union
Berlin vor Wolfsburg und Freiburg und
ganz unten meins Darmstadt und
schlosslicht Bremen
die FIFA hat den spanischen
fußball-präsidenten nuis roviales
vorläufig gesperrt der hatte bei der
Siegerehrung der spanischen
fußballweltmeisterin am Sonntag eine
Spielerin ohne Vorwarnung auf dem Mund
geküsst
ein spanischer Kuss bringt die
internationale Fußballwelt in Unordnung
längst hat diese schon tausendmal
gezeigt es Szene dass wir im Finale aus
den Schlagzeilen verdrängt die Zeitungen
gestern versprachen bereits den
Rücktritt von Louis rubiales den die
Nationalspielerinnen mit einer Streik
Androhung untermauerten auch die
spanische Regierung fordert offen rubyal
ist der Mission die Entschuldigung von
Herrn Ruby alles reichen nicht aus
gestern hatte sich Ruby alles auf einer
außerordentlichen Generalversammlung
geweigert zurück zu treten
nach der Sperre durch die FIFA hat der
spanische Fußballverband sich hinter
seinen verbandchef gestellt es bleibt zu
hoffen dass diese längst schon
schmutzige Angelegenheit sobald wie
möglich entschieden wird
ja allerdings ja
es gibt aktuelle Warnungen vor stark und
Dauerregen im Süden Bayerns mehr vom
Wetter gleich mit Christa Orden das
heute schon mal können Sie an diesem
Abend um 22:45 Uhr sehen mit Maria auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend die kalte Luft die da jetzt
aus dem Norden bis zum immer noch viel
zu warmen Mittelmeer vorankommt die löst
die Entwicklung eines kräftigen Tiefs
aus und das hat auch seiner Nordseite
viel Regen mit dabei und es sind
wirklich enorm Regenmengen die da jetzt
morgen zusammen kommen bis Montagabend
im Südosten Deutschlands bis zu 160
Liter pro Quadratmeter Regen in der
Schweiz und südlich davon deutlich
darüber schützen sich auf jeden Fall vor
Hochwasser Überschwemmungen und
Erdrutschen und jetzt im Moment sind
schwere Gewitter in Bayern unterwegs
sind möglich große Hagel extrem heftiger
Starkregen das Ganze zieht jetzt aber
nach Osten ab und es beruhigt sich etwas
in der Früh da kommt dann der Dauerregen
aus Süden auf und zieht sich im
Tagesverlauf bis nach Brandenburg im
Nordwesten da gibt's im Tagesverlauf im
Nordwesten und Westen Schau und durchaus
auch mal kräftigere Gewitter aber hier
gibt's zwischendurch auch immer mal viel
Sonne die Temperaturen sind deutlich
kühler als zuletzt in der Nacht sinken
die Werte auf 16 bis 8 Grad morgen dann
höchstens noch 24 Grad an der Lausitz im
Dauerregen bleibt es bei 16 Grad und die
neue Woche startet noch mal etwas kühler
der Dauerregen der entschärft sich diese
dauerregenlage entschärft sich dann erst
am Mittwoch tschüss